you will watch TV hi welcome to another
ColdFusion video in this episode we'll
take a look at six situations where the
leaders of companies scoffed at ideas
that would later be fundamental
technologies these are some of the worst
predictions ever made so it's easy to
look back in hindsight and laugh at
these decisions but I think it's more
interesting to practice some empathy
here and look at things from their
perspective this will give us more
understanding and insight into why they
believed what they did at the time let's
get into it
number 6 Western unions president laughs
of the telephone
the year is 1876 and at this time the
telegraph was cutting edge communication
countless times faster and more reliable
than the horse and pony it was truly the
future in 1876 William Orton who was
president of Western Union which had a
monopoly on the Telegraph was offered
the patent for a new invention the
telephone the asking price for the
patent was one hundred thousand dollars
or about two million dollars in today's
currency he considered the whole idea to
be ridiculous
he wrote directly to Alexander Graham
Bell saying after careful consideration
of your invention while it is a very
interesting novelty we have come to the
conclusion that it has no commercial
possibilities what use could this
company make of an electrical toy so
what was his perspective at the time the
Telegraph is a proven technology that
had just disrupted century long forms of
communication - William the telephone
just seemed like a novelty two years
later after the telephone began to take
off Orton realized the magnitude of his
mistake and spent years unsuccessfully
challenging Bell's patents as for
Alexander Graham Bell he kept his
pattern a few decades later his company
which would become AT&T was now the
largest corporation in America the
company would also go on to invent other
fundamental technologies like the
transistor and laser under their belt
Labs Department number five IBM's
president on computers the year is 1943
and the world is in the midst of the
worst conflict ever seen the victory for
the Allies was closed and technology
aided in the defeat of the Axis powers
on many fronts a computer that could
calculate automatically would prove
invaluable during war it was amongst
this backdrop that the president of IBM
Thomas Watson stated I think there is a
world market for maybe five computers so
it was his perspective in 1943 IBM was
into the business of selling punch cards
and producing typewriters as well as
electrical mechanical calculators and
tabulating equipment computers in this
era was still a foreign concept there
were huge machines that took up an
entire room and there was only a few of
them in operation globally there we used
to calculate things like ballistic
trajectories or breaking German codes
for the war effort
these early computers use vacuum tubes
instead of transistors to carry out
their calculations this meant that they
used up a lot of power were extremely
expensive and often break down as vacuum
tubes have burnout just like lightbulbs
if just one chip broke the whole system
would stop working so to Thomas Watson
running a computer simply required too
much effort to be practical for a wider
market and rightly so but of course
today there are countless billions of
computers within billions of devices
worldwide number 4 the co-founder of
20th Century Fox dismisses television
the year is 1946 the war had just ended
and peacetime had just begun TVs were
starting to enter the home in Europe and
America but only just barely the concept
of television was still very new at the
time radio was still the king of
nationwide shared experiences at this
time
Darryl zanuck co-founder of 20th Century
Fox stated television wouldn't be able
to hold on to any market it captures
after the first six months people will
soon get tired of staring at a plywood
box every night so the reasoning at the
time 20th Century Fox was in the
business of film and what a huge
business it was audio had just come to
the theaters 19 years earlier blowing
mines in its wake
moviegoers can now see their favorite
stars sing and dance on the big screen
cinema became a quintessential social
experience a big-screen comfortable
seats food and snacks friends a date or
family by your side how could a tiny
wooden box compete with such a full
experience but as it turned out people
really valued watching content in the
comfort of their own home and the
variety of programs that came out of
television couldn't have been easily
predicted number three Steve Ballmer CEO
of Microsoft dismisses Google
[Music]
[Applause]
the years 2004 and Google had only been
in operation for four years but had
already proven themselves taking a huge
market share among search engines of the
time still Steve Ballmer CEO of
Microsoft - marked Google is not a real
company it's a house of cards
his perspective well there wasn't much
of it it was said in a blind fit of rage
he is the story Markovski was a key
engineer and Microsoft he had been the
principal architect behind Windows NT
which eventually would evolve into
Windows XP he was a big deal and in 2004
he had a meeting with Steve Ballmer to
let him know that he was leaving and
Steve didn't like it just tell me it
isn't Google Ballmer remarked when Locke
offski said he was leaving when Locke
offski confirmed that it was indeed
Google Ballmer allegedly picked up a
chair and throw it across the room if
throwing a chair across the room didn't
demonstrate the ball Matt snapped his
next statement made a crystal clear I'm
not gonna read what he said but here it
is
[Music]
and after that tirade Steve made the
famous remark that Google was indeed a
house of cards and of course today
Google's parent company alphabet is
doing just fine
number two Steve Ballmer is behind the
curve from the first iPhone the year is
2007 and the iPhone was just released to
great fanfare and once again Steve was
behind the curve he is what he said Dave
let me ask you about the iPhone and the
zoom if I may the Zune was getting some
traction and Steve Jobs goes to Macworld
and he pulls out this iPhone what was
your first reaction when you saw that
$500 fully subsidized with the plan like
that that is the most expensive phone in
the world and it doesn't appeal to
business customers because it doesn't
have a keyboard which makes it not a
very good email machine this time his
perspective was a bit more measured the
previous generation of smart phones at
the time were just slowly evolved PDAs
though mostly aimed at business users
who demanded capabilities that
facilitated mobile productivity this
resulted in the merger of mobile
communication like calling an email
being balanced with other functions such
as scheduling and spreadsheet apps as a
central core experience all of these
functions required a full keyboard touch
screens just weren't up to the job until
the iPhone that is with this capacitive
multi-touch technology that Apple had
previously acquired from the finger
Works company - most experts a
touchscreen phone with no buttons seemed
like a stupid idea at first glance but
in reality it allowed a phone to become
a blank canvas and the limits to its
capabilities were only bounded by the
imagination of the app developers such a
method of human-computer interaction
when perfected opened up the smartphone
to an audience
far beyond business users and geeks it
opened it up to everyone
number one Blockbuster Video rejects
Netflix so I think most of us are
familiar with this story in the year
2000 Netflix approached Blockbuster to
sell the company for 50 million dollars
and they got laughed out of the office
from the point of view of Blockbuster it
didn't make sense for people to pay for
a monthly subscription to have DVDs
delivered to their door Netflix would
make the transition from male DVDs to
online streaming around 2007 there were
forward-thinking and ready for the new
digital revolution in personal computing
and internet usage amongst this backdrop
in 2008 blockbusters new CEO Jim keys
said the following in an interview
Netflix
aren't even on the radar screen in terms
of competition our competition is more
like Walmart his reasoning blockbuster
was a huge rental retail company not a
technology company they still had a
massive customer base so there's
virtually nothing to worry about
online streaming was still quite a new
thing it had been tried in the mid 90s
before and was mainly a failure so it
kind of made sense not to pay attention
but of course this would be a fatal
mistake in just two years blockbuster
was filing for bankruptcy and today
Netflix has over 19 billion dollars
worth of assets
so what can we take away from this in
conclusion well I guess you could say
don't let your own biases blind you
seeing things from a fresh perspective
is critical to avoiding mistakes and
this is a general rule it's applicable
throughout life
so that just about rounds out the end of
the video sometimes that really is
interesting to look at things from a
different perspective I hope you got
something from that and if you found
this video interesting feel free to
share it if you need to this channel
subscribe if you liked what you saw this
has been - go go you've been watching
cold fusion and I'll catch you again
soon for the next video
cheers guys have a good one
cold fusion are you thinking
[Music]